oh my god  Rosa's wearing pink Rosa's wearing pink  are we sure it's not a white shirt  that's just been bloodied in a  motorcycle crash maybe it wasn't her  does she have a twin sister if Rosa had  a twin she would have eaten her in the  womb wait pull it stop how come none of  you teased her about it it's Rosa she's  scary guys her unbelievable I once wore  a tie with a splash of purple you guys  called me mr. grapes for two years  forgot about mr. graves if I wore pink  shirt you termina shreds well yeah but  you'd look like a My Little Pony with a  gun let me guess your theater club is  putting on grease and you're playing a  pink lady  if Boyle was wearing a pink shirt I get  it  that's hilarious what's happening Rosa's  the one wearing pink and it's gorgeous  wish I could pull that off dream on  strawberry shortcake yeah nice try mr.  grapes  [Music]  [Applause]  you